faltan pocas horas para que los
hondureños se acerquen a las urnas para
elegir alcaldes diputados y sobre todo
al Presidente de la República la
situación en el país es tensa por lo
menos por lo que hemos visto en las
calles de Tegucigalpa la capital con
vías militarizadas y es que justamente
uno de los retos de estos comicios es
que no se replique lo sucedido en el año
2017 cuando en la noche posterior a las
elecciones el sistema colapso y quién
punteaba como ganador el opositor
Salvador Nasralla amaneció al día
siguiente por debajo del oficialista
Juan Orlando Hernández la denuncia de un
presunto fraude electoral en aquel
entonces fue el detonante para una
insurrección popular
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y la
fuerza pública que dejaron más de 30
muertos ese es el temor que se replique
en estos comicios justamente por el
estrecho margen que separa a los dos
candidatos favoritos de una parte Nasri
pura por el oficialismo y de otra a
Xiomara Castro por la coalición de
izquierda una actualización que quiere
arrebatarle el poder a la derecha que
lleva más de 10 años en el poder y que
ha sido acusada de narcotráfico
represión civil y corrupción política